Every fantasy writer one of the basic questions
you have to settle when you start out writing
your books is how are you going to handle
magic sorcery the the fantasy elements
you see a lot of people writing in secondary world
universes that are very high magic it's something
that anybody can learn and anybody can do i can
make it you can make it you have the recipe it all
comes out right to my mind uh that took the magic
out of magic in magic it's not just the recipe
or the words of the spell it's who you are
who's doing it and what are you feeling when
you're doing it the valyrians while practicing
their blood magic and their fire magic notice
that it didn't matter whether you pronounced
the words of spell right whether you made
a correct sacrifice to the correct guard
all of that may have had some importance
but one of the big things was who you are and
what was your relation particularly to the dragons
what are the dragons like they're
flying beasts they have to have
very large wings and a relatively slender
serpentine body a long tail a long neck
two legs two wings in front they're made to fly
and just strike at their prey from from the air
but then there's the fire issue so many
people associate dragons with breathing fire
leaving that out we just feel wrong they
are creatures of fire they breathe fire
fire doesn't harm them as easily as it would us
and there's something very magical about the fire
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my house of the dragon video on the magic of
dragons they have their own unique type of magic
that's different from the magic that melisandre
the power of the red god that she draws on it's
different from working like the people of the
north the children of the forest even the stark
children do including jon snow jon snow is also
a warg it's also different than the magic of the
children of the forest that bran is now using as
the three-eyed raven so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel house of the
dragon episode 1 is starting now i'll be doing
videos for all the episodes just like my videos
for the game of thrones main series so be sure
to subscribe to get them all i'm also doing a
giveaway for hbo max subscriptions all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and post your
favorite moment from all the trailers on the video
so as george rr martin says when he wrote a song
of ice and fire he wanted magic in the world to
be very different very complex much more complex
than your traditional type of fantasy magic like
it's not as simple as just reading a spell and
activating its effects it's not something that
everybody can pick up and do so there are at least
nine unique types of magic in game of thrones
with a couple subsets each in different terms
for what you call people who practice each type
of magic but some people like melisandre other
followers of the red god practice multiple types
of magic children of the forest also use multiple
types of magic there's elemental control raising
the dead glamouring those are all types of magic
that melisandre uses in the world raising the dead
is also thought of as a different skill from just
flat out necromancy really good example that is
what the night king does is closer to necromancy
than just raising the dead raising the dead is
like bringing someone completely back to life
the nike mostly just raises whites by just turning
the dead into finger puppets melisandre also uses
her enchanted gemstone to glamour herself making
herself appear as if she were still a middle-aged
woman when in fact she's closer to like 200 years
old really cool side detail because the show picks
up about 187 years before the events of game
of thrones season 1 that means that melisandre
is a young girl during the events of house of the
dragons season one but she's from the shadowlands
in asshai so she's not in westeros while house of
the dragon is happening i don't know if they're
going to have a cameo scene with a young version
of melisandre or anything like that there's
divination which are things like greensight and
dragon dreams which are two different things but
essentially the same basic idea seeing versions of
possible futures green sight is something that the
children of the forest all possess naturally in
some works possess like bran is born a greenseer
in the case of dragon dreams it's kind of the
same situation but with people of valyrian
descent it's incredibly rare for someone to be
born with the ability blood magic is meant to
be one of the darkest and rarest types of magic
in the world blood magic is like a broader type
of magic that has a bunch of subsets like you
use it for a bunch of different types of things
really good example is that during game of thrones
season one miri mazdur claims to be a blood mage
have the ability to save khal drogo's life but
she secretly has to sacrifice daenerys unborn
baby rhaego to do it so using blood magic usually
involves literally some sort of blood sacrifice
and because this series is meant to delve into
the history of the valyrians and the targaryens
ancient valyrians also practice forms of blood
magic when they tame dragons initially and started
the art of dragon bonding turning it into more of
a genetic thing that eventually future generations
could just pass on to the next one supposedly
blood magic was also used in the creation of
valyrian steel which i think is one of the reasons
why creating new valyrian steel has become a lost
art when we pick up a house of the dragon because
it requires a lot of magical spells that people
just don't know it's way more complicated
than just finding the right ingredients
on the show there are a lot more references in
easter eggs for the ancient valyrians freehold
before the doom so we do hope we get more lore
about the ancient valyrians in future seasons
alchemy is also considered a completely different
type of magic that's one that's practiced by the
alchemist guild which gets into the creation of
wildfire that we saw during the original series
there's also skin changing which you think of
as warging skin changing is like another ability
that descends from the children of the forest it
started with them and then they slowly passed it
into some of the first men that lived near them
and eventually those first men fought the kings
of winter they started intermarrying and that's
how eventually you're born with stark children who
all have wolf dreams and are capable of warging
when we talk about wolf dreams it's a little bit
different from dragon dreams in the books the
stark children who still have dire wolves that
are still alive have wolf dreams and what's
happening is that when they're asleep they're
basically warging into their direwolves without
realizing it there was a trailer during one of
the early seasons where they kind of teased that
so like jon snow and arya for example still have
dire roles that are still alive they still have
wolf dreams it's just that both jon snow and arya
never practice the ability so they don't know
how to actually work like you actually have to
practice the skill that's why bran is the only one
that can actually do it dragon dreams like i said
are just like literally seeing possible futures
the magic of dragons is george r martin talks
about it being like a completely different thing
it's sort of like a subset of blood magic i think
because of the way they bond with certain types
of valyrian blood really good example of this
is that like everybody at the ancient valyrian
freehold all the houses were not dragon lords
meaning that not everybody who lived in ancient
valyria were bonded to dragons that's where we
get to the velaryons this family here is spelled
differently so velaryons come from ancient valyria
spelled differently but they were not ancient
dragonlords which is why they can't ride dragons
but the targaryens can't because the targaryens in
ancient history were dragon lords so i think we'll
find out through the lore that ancient valyrians
who were dragon lords practice this special type
of blood magic co-mingling their blood using a
lot of really dark arts and spells to basically
domesticate dragons and then pass that ability on
genetically to future generations in their houses
the step to this problem like the reason why you
see a lot of valyrians have white hair but not be
bonded to dragons is because during the last
couple hundred years you have a lot of targaryens
intermarrying with velaryons in their children
then get the gene that way so there are some
valyrians who do have the ability to bond with
dragons best example of that on the house of the
dragon tv show are rhaenys targaryen's children
with corly's velyaron so rhaenys targaryen this
woman here has a dragon called meles she was
born a targaryen she has a dragon just like all
the other targaryens she married corlys velaryon
who is not a dragon rider didn't have the gene
but their children did have the gene but as george
r martin says he wanted the way magic worked in a
song of ice and fire to be very particular that's
why for instance the night king who was a member
of the first men a thousand years ago wasn't born
with the dragon bonding gene originally thus he
could only ride viserion after he had died and
then raised him up as a white using necromancy
like a magical flex tape workaround
without breaking the rules of the universe
when martin says the fire dragons create is a
special kind of fire like the fire itself has
magical properties i think partly that's just the
innate magical power that all dragons are born
with in the way that children of the forest
are born with a really strong affinity for
magic but the big theory is that a lot of these
types of blood magic necromancy the powers of
the night king the white walkers all the children
of the force all come from the same source like
in a larger sense they're all drawing on the same
magical power just using it in very very different
ways or like the dragons and the children of the
forest they're connected to it in different ways
because literally the night king and the
white walkers are creation of the children
of the forest so their magic power is based on
the same powers as the children of the forest
under normal circumstances i would say dragonfire
is just probably better for killing white walkers
because it burns so much hotter than normal fire
but there's also probably some biochemical reasons
for why fire itself is more potent along with why
dragonglass and valyrian steel are so much more
potent in killing white walkers but here's we get
to the magical side of that too like the magical
properties behind the dragons in the targaryens
so on a biological level the dragon's bodies will
just create certain types of chemicals that mix
to create the fire when they're exposed to air
the reason why the fire burns so much hotter is
probably because of the types of chemicals their
bodies produce but it's also probably what
makes their body so much more resistant to
regular types of fire and it's also why i think
that targaryens those of valyrian descent are
burnt by fire nearly as easily because ancient
valyrians use this blood magic spells to literally
bond parts of dragon's genetic code with their
blood so that metaphorically and literally
they became kind of like dragons but remember
there's a lot of magical spells involved with
how they actually got started in ancient valeria
bonding dragons so it wasn't like some ancient
valyrian went up to dragons one day and gave
himself a dragon iv of a bunch of their blood
and suddenly they thought of him as one of their
own the ancient freehold taming dragons is based
a lot on the real world domestication of horses
so just like that it took a long time a lot of
selective breeding because this is a song of
ice and fire blood magic spells along the way
so it wasn't like an overnight thing in order to
get to the point on the show here where targaryens
could hatch a new dragon egg and that new dragon
wouldn't just eat them right on the spot like
i've talked about in the past the show is going
to get into a lot of the personalities between
the different dragons like all the dragons will
have their own different types of personalities
but if we're talking about animals they're mostly
like cats very standoffish but when they bond with
someone they become incredibly loyal but that's
why just like anybody off the street can't just
walk up and ride them like if you tried to go up
and pick up a random cat it would just run off
george rr martin talks a lot about the biology
of dragons just dragons growing over time
and even though it's not magic just on a
biological level dragons never stop growing
the longer they live the more they consume over
time the bigger they'll get this is like a really
easy size chart to just help show you so like the
biggest dragons are typically the oldest ones when
the show begins balerion the black dread has died
recently he was about 200 years old when he died
making vegar the biggest one on the show but also
the oldest and they say that as dragons get older
they become more like b-52 bombers much harder to
take off in much harder to land in but even more
deadly in the air flying around on vhagar is kind
of like flying around on a giant fortress there'll
be 17 total dragons that are alive during this
period will meet over the course of the series
but i believe during season 1 we're only going
to meet 9 of them we've seen a bunch during the
trailers but not every single one i'll talk about
them a little bit more as they pop up in episodes
if you have any other questions about the
dragons how they work or the magic behind
them how their abilities work just write them
below in the comments and i'll be sure to add
them to my bonus videos my full house of the
dragon episode 1 video will post later tonight
be sure to enable alerts for my channel so you
don't miss it everyone click here for my house
of the dragon review video and click here for
my new house of the dragon trailer breakdown
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!